a huge fire in downtown las vegas last
night the smoke and the flames filled
the sky happened just before eight
o'clock last night near maine and
charleston yeah you may have seen it
bianca holman joining us now live
downtown with a look at the scene bianca
earlier you mentioned that you could
still smell it in the air
yeah you're absolutely right so you can
see that this two-story building right
here still you can see ash you can still
see smoke but the fire was contained in
about 30 minutes and we're told no
injuries were reported so again you can
still see the damage the char the damage
of this two-story building so in this
video you can see the large flames
taking over
taking over an empty warehouse some of
those flames powerful enough to go
through the roof the fire and smoke
could be seen for miles fire crews say
they got into the scene very quickly and
controlled the fire within 30 minutes
the fire was contained just to this
warehouse there was concern about the
envy energy substation next door
there's a substation next door
to the building
but it's pretty well
insulated around they've got special
stuff around it
it didn't get outside the building that
was on fire
we knew about it we put defense forces
up there right away to make sure that it
wouldn't spread to the sub station
fire crews are still investigating the
cause but some witnesses say they saw
what might have been homeless people
going in and out of the building and a
good news that there were no reported
injuries the fire was just contained to
this two-story building so once we find
out the cause we'll keep you all updated
online and on air reporting live bianca
holman 8 news now